Black Adam is a menacing figure not
afraid to kill to deliver his brand of
justice but how does Dwayne Johnson
compare to his alter ego as the DC
anti-hero the newest DC extended
Universe film Black Adam was just
released at theaters last week on
October 21st 2022 directed by Jama
Colette Sarah the film stars Dwayne The
Rock Johnson as The titular Black Adam a
former slave from condak who possesses
the same Powers as a similar character
Shazam they include gifts like super
strength and speed as well as more
psychological Powers such as courage and
wisdom after being imprisoned for nearly
5 000 years Black Adam finally escapes
and is ready to bring Justice to the
world you can be the destroyer of this
world
or you can be its savior while Johnson
leads the pack the film also boasts an
impressive list of Supporting Cast
members this includes Pierce Brosnan as
Dr Fate a senior member of the just the
Society of America Aldous Hodge as
Hawkman the GSA leader Noah centineo as
Adam Smasher a young GSA member who can
control his size and strength and
quintessa Swindell as Cyclone a JSA
member who can control wind and sound
then there is Marwan kenzari as sabak
the militant leader of the criminal
organization intergang and Sarah Shahi
as professor and resistance fighter
Adriana Tomas an ally to the JSA in a
September 2022 interview with Vanity
Fair Noah centineo discussed Black Adam
and opened up about working with Dwayne
Johnson for the film centeneo for one
had nothing but praise for Johnson as an
actor co-star and role model centeneo
said Dwayne Johnson is 99 more present
than most people they say don't meet
your Idols not true with Dwayne centeneo
also noted that working on Black Adam
acted as a learning experience for him
as well thanks in part to Johnson saying
Pierce Brosnan is to the right the rock
is to the left I'm getting a master
class the actor then spoke again about
working with Johnson in an October 2022
interview with pink Villa alongside his
co-star quintessa Swindell both Stars
had nothing but praise for Johnson
Swindell began by noting that he is
funnier than they expected and made
everyone laugh on set constantly then
added also just to work with and be
around and to learn from and he's
incredibly giving Santa Neo added that
one of the first things he noticed which
Swindell wholeheartedly agreed with is
that Johnson's social media presence
matches up to what he's like in real
life centeneo said so I feel like he's
very honest about who he is which is
tight back in August 2021 Pierce Brosnan
was already beginning to publicly praise
Dwayne Johnson for his work in Black
Adam while speaking with hot living for
an interview Boston was filming Black
Adam at the time of the interview so his
opinions on his co-star were fresh
rossnan noted that due to the nature of
the film he didn't spend a ton of time
on set working with Johnson but that he
has respect for his co-star overall he
said as for Dwayne I don't know the man
but I've got great admiration for him
and what he's created for himself in
life and how he conducts himself with
the World At Large so we go to set and
get on with the work and that's what you
have to do rosinan then praised Johnson
again a month later while speaking to
collider in September 2021 to promote
2021's Cinderella Brosnan gave fans some
early insight into what to expect from
Johnson's superhero performance the
former James Bond actor said it's an
ensemble piece Black Adam you have
Dwayne who's at the Pinnacle of his Fame
and Fortune and success and popularity
he is magnificent as Black Adam
[Music]